boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still on site at Indy BIOS demo day
number eight we are now speaking with
Kevin Honaker hello hi thanks so much
for coming on the show yeah really
appreciate it
you see you of biome sense yes and teach
us about what the pitch was about yes so
biome sense what we're doing is we're
building an integrated hardware software
and data base platform to massively
scale microbiome data it's a little bit
of a confusing sort of way of
explanation it's hard for someone not in
the space but what we've done is we've
built a bio sensor that actually gets
installed in the patient home in like
your home right in your home bathroom
and it essentially continuously tracks
your gut microbiome and I don't are you
familiar with the gut microbiome this is
so complicated yes yes yes so basically
you know the microbiome so much research
has come out in recent years right
showing like how important it is how
it's linked to X Y Z I mean like you
know we keep getting surprised about all
the ways it matters but one of the
themes is like we've spent all this time
and all this money but really like we
still barely understand it and one of
the biggest problem is it is the
microbiome is incredibly complex but
more importantly it changes very rapidly
right so you can go to bed in you know
at night and wake up in the morning and
you have 10% of the microbes that you
did when you went to bed because you
starve them to death right over
overnight so they kind of shrink down in
size so that's how quickly these things
can change they change very rapidly when
you're sick right especially right so
that's like the problem and but in
clinical research today it's basically
impossible to track those changes
because getting that much data right
ideally I need to be measuring you every
single day to make sure I can see those
changes but what if I could only measure
you want some month and that's what it's
like today and so we can't see these
changes we're missing incredibly
important data and that's a huge part of
the prime for the microbiome so we solve
that by building a hardware component
that goes in the patient home and
continuously tracks gut microbial first
is submitting monthly exactly myself
right exactly
and this is on the toilet yeah it
attaches to your home toilet and it just
passively collects a stool sample every
time use the bathroom like you don't
have to you wouldn't even know it's
there
very very quiet smoother may just we
only it's a very small sample you know
so we have built something that actually
processes that right there on-site and
then we combine this with a time series
lytx platform and then longitudinal
reference database sort of create an
end-to-end microbiome data solution yeah
so we collected data we analyzed it
right we link it to these clinical
outcomes and then we've course store
that for later use and knowledge down
the line so that's what we're doing yeah
you've gotta get it on a like a daily
basis I mean you gave that example of
you'd literally go to bed and your
microbiome is young you said it so it
shrunk absolutely okay because there
were something for it to feed on and
then not so much and then usually that's
what's the calling is it's like eat eat
yeah feed right the next yeah yeah that
would control are we yeah but yeah no
it's it's definitely in the thing
especially when clinically right so if
you get sick so like your microbiome
when you're healthy might be one thing
right but then you get sick and then
your micro biomes might change depending
on what it is right or you start taking
a drug right and then it's gonna change
you change your diet right all these
things all these things can do the
changes in like recent evidence papers
gonna like these changes are critical
like this is what actually matters right
but research to date has just ignored
them not because they not important but
because it's difficult to collect it so
if I eat a breakfast that is like six
eggs or something sure
or when I at night if I maybe eat a
couple scoops of ice cream
these are drastically affecting the
microbiome and to be able to analyze it
yeah it's just even you know changing
diet right yeah absolutely yeah no salad
in all this right it'll definitely
change it and you know that's that's
just eating your food you're exactly
right it's things like when you start
talking about clinically like
interventions and stuff that it gets
really really quickly right so we've
seen cases where the micro bond can
dramatically swing over the course of a
week right like if you get sick it
changes then it comes back right and it
responds to your body in a lot of ways
right and so sometimes it's the cause of
sickness right sometimes that's a reason
you're sick other times it is because
you're sick right and so you know
tracking and understanding these is
really really critical for the research
it is it is frankly required to push
microbiome research to the next step and
it's something we've been missing it's
been a glaring gap and the research to
date I think most people know this in
the field it's it's not really a
controversial opinion
you know and so yeah so we're plugging
that gap and now let's um let's get into
the the hardware and software so okay so
yeah so what I'm what are we looking at
in terms of a unit that goes in the
toilet that collects the sample yeah and
I mean probably one of the most simple
questions is does it affect if I have to
plunge the toilet like I'm not gonna
break it apart yeah how does so it
really goes like underneath like the
toilet see it's kind of a good way to
describe it yeah without going too much
into detail right now about exactly like
how it looks like but yeah so we're
actually playing around a couple
different designs so actually this is
believe it's funny because people like
to talk about the collection sykes I
think that's like easy to understand
right but it's actually the least
important part of what we do the hard
part is actually what we do after we
collect the software processing well
even the hardware actually so you
collect a sample but then what do you do
with it alright did you have to like
wash it back out you have to do like a
basically eyes yeah exactly and so
that's where like a lot of the hard work
right and a lot of the hard engineering
is done so we've actually developed this
proprietary system that collects a
sample for a current MVP we just isolate
that microbial DNA and we store that and
that's actually stable and long solution
we're adding a low cost screening assay
so we're developing that separately it's
not in our MVP but it'll be in the full
system right that essentially does a
low-cost screening assay so we can
actually be looking at the microbiome
every single day for a couple bucks a
day and so that's right and then we also
store all the DNA for people who want to
do deeper sequencing right they want to
really know everything that's there and
so we can do that as well except we have
basically all the data they could
possibly want so we like to think about
it is like we can do both the breath or
at the screen right and then the depth
by having the DNA for later with lab a
sequencing okay so I'm so at a cost of
just a dollar a couple dollars per
screening yeah that's well that's our
cost so we charge $300 a patient a month
for the whole system okay three years
old patient okay okay
and that's probably somewhere around
maybe like 200 samples or sorry 20
samples yeah give or take I mean we
actually prices 30 but yeah it's
probably gonna be more likely around 20
okay donation they also purchased a
hardware unit to put in themselves no
they don't oh 300 so what we get for
that is like we basically
stall it we maintain it we do
consumables all because they can't do
software we have to be doing the right
way exactly so we do everything we're a
full-service provider which Dan yes you
have to like an installer that knows how
to do this stuff so yeah probably seems
like potentially we don't need a plumber
something I need a plumber but like it
gives or maybe your to your own team
like it gives you more jobs of like
going on yeah yeah okay let's let's
break I know you're working on the
designs but so okay so so we're
literally like if this is you know
stored right underneath that toilet
ledge yeah then it has to somehow have
some sort of like a suction ability to
take them like ask to detect when a turd
has been made versus well when the poop
comes instead of the PE exactly so you
have to detect that and then you have to
take in a sample but like if it doesn't
break apart if it's just a really hard
chunk of it's a smooth one most type of
stuff and so then you try and you know
soup out a sample then you bring it in
for the processing and then there's some
how you're able to have it process that
yes and then upload the data from there
through the homes like Wi-Fi like an IOT
style yeah laughs I and then move that
sample back out and keep that area
somewhat clean for the next time this is
hard
yeah so you basically describe the
workflow we don't do it the way you were
just talking about like some pieces so
for example some pieces are disposable
so actually part of like our innovation
it's kind of interesting right the way
we've built as some of our innovation
right is taking things that are not
normally disposable and doing them in a
way that they're disposable that's maybe
like a bad way some of the micro
fluidics right some of the Mike yeah
okay yeah and what I ship it back like
to recycle it or something like yeah
well no it's just gone used throw it out
yeah so it's like incredibly cheap so
like that's part of what we've done
right is develop the system
with all these questions in mind right
so our system has answers to all those
questions not going into engineering for
all of it right
the nice thing it's like I like to say
look like we've we've spent a lot of
time and work thinking on this but we're
not exactly SpaceX here right it's it's
you know in terms of what you're what
you do not yet exactly but in terms like
collecting the sample right like you
could probably like you've thought of
all the major problems right there right
and trust me if you sat down for a
couple weeks and really thought about it
on about you
you know you'd come to it really quickly
this is so hard
yeah if it's the second part it's a
processing that's really really hard and
so that's where we've had you know some
amazing expertise work the University of
Chicago very closely really helped put
together this advanced system and then
you know long term we want to add the
assay and then the Wi-Fi believe it or
not that's actually from a development
perspective is pretty straightforward
it's just expensive and time consuming
so that's why it's not in the MVP
but it'll be in subsequent iterations of
the biosensor and then what is is this
like a meta transcriptomic analysis or
what are you doing yeah no so we just
store right now we just store the
microbial DNA right so yeah no we're not
doing that we're not going that advanced
so we just do basically if you know
anything you can do that so you know
shotgun metagenomics probably what most
people will end up doing with it when
they actually sequence it and then our
low-cost screening assay essentially
mimic 16s but it's not 16s because much
deeper okay yeah okay and then you
really want to be able to deliver like
an insight to the to them via their like
device the computer or their home or
whatever yeah I mean eventually yes
right but we're actually starting on the
clinical research side so the idea is
you're an investigator you're a
scientist right you're running a trial
and you want to know for example how
does the microbiome right how does the
microbiome change over time when you I
don't know get cancer writers start
taking a certain drug or something like
that right so you're gonna hire us and
you're gonna have your patients and
we're gonna go into those patients we're
install this device in their home right
they're gonna use it to get that data
and then we help the investigator then
basically get that data figure out
what's going on and then run the
analyses and then say okay wait a minute
like these things this is there's like
the microbiome is influencing the
clinical outcome of that patient right
and so we're basically going back to the
beginning of microbiome science yeah
we're supporting basic research to help
make these discoveries yeah really helps
the clinical settings that follow with
the patients to follow up on a day to
day basis right patients right we're you
know the facts matters microbiome is
just not in a position where even if I
gave this to you and I put it in your
home right there's and you use it
faithfully every day right I that data
basically is worthless
in that because I just wouldn't have to
do with it right I wouldn't I wouldn't
be able to help you with it I'm here
until we
it's a healthy gut vibe no people's one
of the one of the biggest challenges the
microbiome is faced is that people
certain you know certain companies so
you know some are good some are not but
basically people have said microbiome
science is really hard but you know it's
much easier marketing oh yeah you're
convincing a consumer that it actually
has science behind it when it doesn't
and so that's where like a lot of
microbiome has gone so like yeah like
the whole idea of like I hope the gut no
one knows about the gut is no one else I
mean there's certainly there's
hypotheses and like there's some
evidence here and there but then they
start even you know you see papers
coming out even like literally the last
few months right I'm like beyond like
that yeah this is this deadly pathogen
in your gut right yes that's bad news
but like in terms of like diversity I'm
or diversity is typically better right
but like how much like sometimes like
two people can both be perfectly healthy
one's really diverse one's not right and
so outside of these like certain
diseases like IBD and Crohn's or where
pets aren't really well explored
we barely are beginning to even have a
basic understanding of what's healthy
and up and what's not much less like for
a certain disease right we're just tired
like generally not even now anytime but
specific disease we're not even close
so what biome sense is essentially
trying to do is take us back to the
beginning do the research do the science
with a level of data that is
exponentially greater than anything
that's been done before
we provide 30 times the data minimum the
exact same cost and so we're basically
to go back to these scientists we're
gonna arm them with exponentially more
data than they've ever had before and
start from the beginning
use that and then that's what's gonna be
needed to unlock the potential of the
microbiome the treatments will follow
the consumer use will follow we have to
start with the science yeah science is
hard but that's where it has to start
yeah and then biome census rate that
you're raising a round yes and also so
what is that and then also what are you
gonna be seeking for talent and the
first like clinical deployments this
type of stuff yeah so we're raising
one-and-a-half million right now and so
in terms of talents we just hired at my
clinic engineer we're about to hire
mechanical engineer and then we're
probably to add a third engineer or
someone with wet lab experience and
downline 104 Maddox as well but it's a
the biggest need for us right now is
that third person that like what lab
experience microbiome experience who can
help us for some the assay development
another work okay awesome
yeah this is this
and awesome those looking forward so the
first deployments of this absolutely and
and being able to follow up like you
said just being able to have a greater
degree of yeah understanding the
microbiome it's a goal yes thanks for
coming
no absolutely shitty use thank you for
everyone tuning in we greatly appreciate
left to hear our thoughts in the
comments below in the episode take out
the links below to biome stencils check
out the links below to indie bio support
the artists entrepreneurs don't the
scientists around the world that you
believe in support them help them grow
support simulation our links are below
help us grow as well and also share more
content like this for your friends
families people online on social media
share it around and get more people
talking about the gut microbiome and how
to understand it go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams and so
we're all do greatly appreciate it
thanks for tuning in we'll see you soon
peace